[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to the
stanford mba maximizing the classroom
and academic experience panel my name is
lisa jananjali and i'm a director of mba
admissions
as well as an alumni of the stanford mba
program and i'll be joined today by some
of my fellow alumni who will also share
their experiences about what it's like
both inside and outside the classroom
at the stanford graduate school of
business or stanford gsb
just to know what to expect for today's
session really our main focus is to
allow you
an opportunity to engage with our
community and to really learn more about
the academic experience at the stanford
gsb
we'll talk a little bit more about the
resources that are available to you to
build your toolkit
you'll have an opportunity to meet our
panelists i'll start us off with a
little bit of q a
and then really we want to address your
questions
so at any point in today's session if
you have a question
feel free to pop that into the q a box
and our panelists
will try to address that if you see a
question that someone else has asked
that you particularly like
feel free to click on that little thumbs
up symbol which will upvote it and we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can
in the approximate hour that we have
together today
but let's talk a little bit about all
the resources that are available to you
as you build your toolkit at the gsb
this is
truly a transformative educational
experience
and one of the things i love about the
gsb is that
we use whatever pedagogy that really
optimizes your learning outcomes
so it's going to vary class by class and
even within a class sometimes week by
week
you're going to be exposed to case
studies and project based courses
role plays simulations you might
actually be rolling up your sleeves and
building a prototype
in one of your design oriented courses
you might be participating in an
action-based learning program and
partnering with different corporations
or you might be in some courses that are
maybe a bit more
internal focused and you're really
thinking about your own personal
leadership
style and getting a lot of really
important leadership coaching and
mentoring
your first year is predominantly the
core curriculum we want to make sure
that you're grounded on all of those
general management disciplines
but even during your core you'll see
some different levels based on your
experiences to date and what you've
studied and what you've been working in
towards the end of your first year
you'll start taking some elective
courses and your second year is entirely
elective courses
so if you'd like to go deep in a
particular area you absolutely can
but more often than not we find our
students rounding out their skill sets
and their knowledge in a few different
areas where they have
interest at the business school there
are a few different research centers and
learning hubs that you can take
advantage of
so for example our center for social
innovation or
our center for entrepreneurial studies
but one of the wonderful things i love
about stanford gsb
is that you're not just within that
business school bubble but instead you
are a part of that entire
stanford university ecosystem and you
have access to all
seven different stanford university
graduate schools
so stanford is home to some of the top
programs in a number of different fields
whether that's law or medicine or
education or engineering the humanities
earth sciences
there are all these disciplines readily
available to you and we say take
advantage of that
take classes across the street as we say
and approximately eighty percent of our
mba students do take classes in other
parts of stanford university
and these days about 20 percent of our
mba students are actually pursuing a
joint or a dual degree during their time
in our mba program so maybe they're
doing another master's program
or a law degree or a medical degree or
something else in addition to their mba
and then throughout your time at
stanford you're not alone
there's this whole team of folks who are
there to support you on your journey
and this ranges from academic and career
and student life advisors
leadership fellows communication coaches
the faculty obviously who are here to
help you and support you
and a whole host of general health and
mental health services that are
available to you
but let's hear directly from some of our
panelists and some of our alumni
an opportunity to meet them i'll have
each of our panelists if you wouldn't
mind
briefly introducing yourselves we'll go
in the order that we see
um here on the screen so diego if you'd
like to start us off uh
welcome my name is diontanea i'm from
lima peru
i i was at the gsb between 2016 and 18.
during that time i incubated a social
enterprise called latin american
leadership academy
which i have been running full-time ever
since
through epandemic which has been a lot
of fun uh so happy to answer questions
around
um the social impact the social
innovation the entrepreneurship side of
the gsb
how the professors the alumni community
have been instrumental
in my journey and more great to meet you
i think that makes me next i'm alana
i was gsb class of 2020 and i am now
talking at you from houston texas
where i'm a consultant for dane before
that
i grew up in portland oregon went to a
tiny college called the olin college of
engineering and by tiny i mean
80 people a year truly tiny and everyone
was an engineer
ran away from engineering did a masters
in england
in european literature and then a
fulbright year
also focused on literature and theater
in germany
followed that up with working as a
product manager in tech for yahoo
and then came to the gsb and who knows
where i'm going next
but i had a great time taking advantage
of
all the things the dsp had to offer so
looking forward to talking to you about
it
everyone my name is jorge i'm gsb class
of 2020
and i'm originally from peru also from
lima but i grew up in orange county
in southern california where i am right
now visiting my family
and i currently live full-time in san
francisco
so close by to the gsb i did my
undergrad at stanford where i studied
computer science and economics for
undergrad
then i did a computer science master's
degree
also at stanford and then actually
during my cs
masters i worked on an interdisciplinary
class in the school of engineering
with a couple of students from the gsb
and actually that's one of the big
factors that
motivated me to apply to the gsb program
so i did
both of my graduate degrees at stanford
but not through the duo program because
i applied while i was
doing the cs masters but i just really
enjoyed the perspective
that the gsb students brought in terms
of their business knowledge as well as
their interpersonal skills so i wanted
to learn
the same skills that they seem to have
gained at the gsp and that's what
motivated me to apply and
have a background in tech i work as a
product manager and i'm particularly
interested
in emerging technologies like artificial
intelligence
and blockchain and crypto
hi everyone i'm josh i graduated about
three weeks ago from the stanford gsb
uh in undergrad i was a bioengineering
major with plans to become this
physician scientist
md phd uh professor
i quickly realized that maybe that
wasn't exactly what i wanted to do and
so
i took a leave from the md phd program
at johns hopkins to
launch my first startup a kidney disease
diagnostics company
as a technical co-founder but i quickly
realized that
i actually wanted to be on the business
side of things and so that's why
i knew that i had to intend to stand for
gsb so i could learn the business skills
and build a network
necessary to make those dreams come true
and so
now that i've graduated i am the
co-founder and ceo of glyptic
biotechnologies which is
a biotech startup based here in san
francisco
where i am currently located hi everyone
great to you great to be here
uh i'm sebastian serra i'm from mexico
city that's where i am now
i graduated from the gsp in 2017 and i
did a dual degree
with the kennedy school at harvard
university which is
school of kind of government at harvard
where i studied a master's in economics
and international development
um before that grad school staying tight
i actually
worked for my undergrad institution for
yale uh
helping to invest the university's
endowment and things kind of around
natural resources
and energy uh and now i i do that in
mexico and latin america
doing investments in decarbonization and
renewable energy basically
um so happy to talk about uh what it's
like to do a dual degree
especially when you're not in the same
location and moving across across places
uh or anything else that you guys want
to talk about
well thank you i'll start us off with um
a few questions before we go to our
audience questions so again our audience
if you have anything on your mind please
feel free to go to that q a box
and type some questions in but a general
question for all of our panelists
here um what was one of your favorite
classes or academic experiences
and why my favorite class of the gsb
was reputation management by allison
kluger
which is a class where you actually ask
your classmates and other people that
are important to you in your life
how they view you and what their
perception
of you is and is was one of the best
ways for me to get feedback about
how i show up in the world and how i
could
decide to change or not change different
aspects of myself
and so i gained so much from that class
and it was a really good
experiential class in which you really
went out and
sought feedback on how to improve
yourself
this is hard because i have like five
and i was really hoping that other
people would go first and say some of
them
so that i could save whichever one
hadn't been covered
but if i have to pick one i'm going to
pick dynamics of the global wine
industry
which is taught by alyssa rapp it is a
great class
so great that i essentially took it
twice once as a student and once as a ta
and it's not just because you taste a
lot of really great wine in class
although you do and that's definitely a
benefit
but i also think that that class was
actually the best
strategy class i took at the gsb
we had a lot of foundation strategy
classes which give you
a lot of frameworks which are useful but
this
really applied it all to an industry
that is really difficult to navigate
right global highly regulated it deals
with
kind of all of the problems you could
imagine an industry has to deal with
and learning from people and really
brainstorming ways to
build successful businesses in spite of
that was a really great education for me
also alyssa rapp is an amazing human
being and well worth taking a class with
just to get to meet her
all right this next one sebastian i'll
have you start us off here
um we talked about how the stanford gsb
utilizes a variety of teaching methods
ranging from case to role plays
simulations all sorts of different
things here
how do you think that enhanced your um
learning experience during your time at
stanford
sure no i think as i as i was reflecting
for the seminar
i was really thinking of the exact point
that you're making these on the
diversity of classes that you take
and so i when i think of the types of
classes i took i took
a class um that's kind of gsb and part
of the design code school called design
for extreme affordability where we were
literally
using our hands to build a
fertilizer for uh farmers in africa
we took a very hardcore finance class
that feels you know
very much as you're in a lecture
listening to a
hugely successful professor on financial
economic theory and probably not
understanding 50 of what is happening
but you're in that
in that lecture um and then you you also
have classes that that are really about
kind of role playing
and and and and putting yourself in in a
in a practicing mode on things that now
in my career i
i really value you know so i took a
class for example called
managing difficult conversations with
with irv grosbeck who's probably one of
the
um kind of most famous professors at the
at the gsb
and and you're practicing firing people
oh and so now
in my job i had never fired someone
before and i had to recently fire
someone and
i was immediately thinking of the
practice i had at least had doing that
once at the gsb
um and then you also have classes like
startup garage and these kind of classes
where you're literally
kind of building your business and and
have an incredible amount of resources
to to build that business so my wife
also went to the gsb
and she now has a startup uh that she
started at
in this class startup garage and was
able to spend you know
six months during her second year
getting credit for building that class
and so
in addition to having that diversity of
literally every
kind of type of education you can
imagine i i also think that that
diversity actually translates to very
real life uh valuable experience post
gsb
uh and that kind of diversity has been
at least for me
uh really critical in my career post
post pro stanford so
hopefully that answered your questions
absolutely
uh this next question i'll um point
towards alana diego and
josh um what was your relationship like
with faculty how did you interact with
them
in or out of the class in different ways
alana maybe if you'd like to start us
off
sure well you take a lot of classes at
once at the gsb
so the reality is you're not going to be
best friends with every single faculty
member um but i did definitely take time
outside of class to get to know
particular faculty members
where i loved the class or where i felt
the strong connection with them
um and that looked like going to office
hours sometimes but it also just looked
like
asking them to take some random time
with me and i'd never had
anyone say no and usually they just
desperately want to help you one reason
i really
love alyssa rapp is i showed up to this
one-on-one that i had asked her to have
with me
and she sat down and she said okay what
do you want to do during your internship
what do you want to do post gsb
and i said well i want to explore
working for a performing arts non-profit
i'm really hoping to get an
internship there and she went great uh
here are four
leaders of performing arts nonprofits
that i have personal connections to
which ones would you like email
introductions to
and that was actually how i got my
summer internship
at a major ballet company absolutely no
relation to what she was teaching
i expected we were going to talk wine in
her class
but what she really just wanted was to
be useful to me
as a student and i found that across the
professors that i connected with
and i really loved getting to know them
better and having them wanting to
marshal their resources to help me
that's a hugely valuable asset while
you're at the gsb
diego how about your experience
interacting with faculty
wow fantastic so um
i remember in my in my interview
um i was told that one of the most
underutilized assets of the gcp are the
professors
and i kind of blew it off as like oh
this is just a marketing stunt
and at the gsb and then especially post
gsb i'm blown away by the caliber of the
professors
they truly are leaders in their
industries
um and amazing people so some gsp
professors
have been unofficial and official
advisors
uh for lala uh the social enterprise i
founded
some have been donors i'm not gonna tell
you whom uh
some helped us find
uh our main donors some helped us uh
get foundation support in the foundation
that they worked at
um yeah they've been they've been
amazing and also now in hindsight lisa
that for example we're trying to
find certain funders or to get to work
with some foundations i'm like ah
it's so hard to get to eric schmidt now
it would have been nicer to
take his class or it would have been
nicer to take the class with
say the ceo of a meteor network now it's
really hard that i'm on the outside so
definitely wonderful professors and
great opportunity to get to meet them
while you're a student
at the gsb outside of class and josh how
about your experiences interacting with
faculty
yeah i have i've had amazing experiences
with faculty both sort of in the
classroom setting
related to the academics as well as
outside related to
my startup and entrepreneurial endeavors
and i served as the ta for multiple
faculty
i did a independent study with a faculty
member on
kidney kidney disease in the u.s in the
healthcare system
where we were able to work with i was
able to work with five other my fellow
classmates on this independent study
project
really dive deep into one area of
healthcare that i was really passionate
about
um and having the support of faculty
through as
in the academic project was really
valuable in terms of
getting access to people who had
information that
maybe i would not have been able to talk
to otherwise
and even for my entrepreneurial
endeavors i have to say that the faculty
at the gsu both
are just so kind and willing to help
but also so well connected and
successful in their own right
and so it's what some one of the faculty
members is an investor in my company now
one of them i use as a reference check
for
my investors who were considering
investing and that investor told me that
they were so impressed that this faculty
member said such good things about me
that that was a one of the reasons that
they decided to invest actually
and another faculty was
actually knew one of my potential board
members
and was able to provide me with deep
insight into how this person operated as
a board member
and so truly i think the resources and
the value you can get from the faculty
relationships i think
this runs the entire gamut of all
possible things
and so i've had a really great
experience getting to know
the faculty i've taken the classes with
and even those ones i haven't even taken
classes with
great this next question
if there's just one thing i would add
just um from more of a social
dynamic with professors um at least my
housemates and i are second year people
who live in houses
um and so we did this but a lot of
people did this
every every wednesday we would invite a
different professor
to come have dinner with us and they'd
spend you know three to five hours with
us
having dinner drinking wine talking
about academic things talking about
their lives
and i was just always so blown away by
the willingness of people to just kind
of do that and engage with you
in a more social setting in addition to
to the points a lot of josh and
diego brought up the more academic this
was just a purely social
experience that was wonderful wonderful
i've heard many of those stories too
of you know some of the top us economic
advisors who are faculty are off
mountain biking during the weekend with
students and things so i think they're
just wonderful connections that are made
during your time there
um jorge this next question uh we'll
have you start us off here um
what are some ways that students can
help shape the academic experience
either for themselves or through others
yeah there's so many different ways that
you can get involved with shaping the
academic experience one of the big ways
that i participated in during my
time at stanford gsb was as a member of
the academic committee which is a part
of the gsb
student government that focuses on
shaping the academic experience
serving as a liaison between the
students and the faculty
and that included things like collecting
feedback from students
about the different classes especially
with a focus on first years
making sure that people feel like
they're being supported in the first
quarter as they're transitioning into
the gsb to make sure they have
the tutoring support that they need for
some of the more difficult classes
to make sure that professors are
providing a
type of curriculum that engages students
and resonates with students
both in terms of the material with
regards to the companies being discussed
as well as the diversity of the content
focusing on female founders
minority entrepreneurs that type of
thing to make sure that
the content appeals to a broad range of
students from all backgrounds
in addition to that i worked on
organizing
our quarterly academic small group
dinners
which connected small groups of students
with a faculty member
and we provided funding for that for
students to
get reimbursed for either going out to
dinner or ordering dinner to
eat at the dorms or at their house with
different faculty so this is a great
opportunity
for students to connect with particular
faculty members whether it's from their
existing classes or people who they
actually haven't taken the classes of
but they want to learn more about
and this is a great opportunity to build
those more personal relations with
faculty because sometimes they'll be
willing to share some more personal
aspects of their life or their
background that you might not get to
hear about
within the classroom and for me actually
some of those dinners
helped me learn about professors in a
way that like
i guess when i took their class maybe i
didn't expect i would
connect with them on such a personal
level but speaking to them during dinner
i found that we had a lot in common
and then they're professors that i've
maintained contact with and i'm close
with
in the long term and then another great
way to get involved is
uh connecting your experience with the
different student groups to your
academic experience
and that's something i did i was one of
the co-founders of the stanford
blockchain club
which is an undergraduate and graduate
interest group for people
who are interested in blockchain and
cryptocurrencies
and um there's a couple of professors
who were starting
crypto and blockchain classes uh my year
and
they didn't have that much technical or
academic experience in the space but
from my
computer science engineering degree i
had worked with dan bonnet who's one of
the top researchers in the field
so i helped make a lot of the
connections both to academics in the
field as well as to entrepreneurs
working in the blockchain space
to get speakers and to figure out case
studies for the various classes
as well as to host small group events to
connect
students to the speakers that came to
visit in a more intimate setting after
we had these classes with the
guests that we invited and then through
my experience as a first-generation and
low-income student
i also founded the first-gen low-income
stanford gsb club and through this club
i helped to
advocate for providing more resources
and opportunities for students who come
from this background who are the first
to go
to college from their families who may
need additional financial support
because they have
a lot of financial stresses from the
families back home
and in this way for example we advocated
for
additional tutoring sessions maybe for
students who came from
different academic backgrounds to make
sure that they were supported as they
started the gsb
as well as additional ways to
provide uh financial support especially
to students who maybe have families or
other
dependents that they're supporting as
well so basically like
the gsb provides so many opportunities
for you to take the initiative
um and shape your experience and the
experience of your peers
in whatever way you want and i actually
just thought of two other really cool
ways
but in um in my uh
gsb experience i also helped to lead the
stanford ai salon which was a speaker
series
that brings to brings in speakers from
the artificial intelligence field
and that was a great way to connect
artificial intelligence from a technical
standpoint
to the social impact that that has
across
the world and in terms of economics
social issues
and then also through that i helped
advise
the fda on their policies around
regulating artificial intelligence in a
medical context so that was also
experience related to academics nice
nice
i want to build off something that jorge
said kind of in how you were talking
about
um the blockchain course the ai kind of
interactions
you know we talked about how stanford
gsb is part of that much larger
ecosystem at stanford university
um so maybe um alana and sebastian if
you want to tackle this question did you
take advantage
of classes or learning opportunities
outside the business school
or elsewhere and tell us a little bit
more about that
alana do you want to start sure yes i
took quite a few across the street
classes which is what we call
gsp years taking classes outside of the
jsb
one was business related and really to
supplement my gsb education
and that was the negotiation class at
stanford law school
the gsb also has a negotiations class
the law school one is taught in a little
bit of different format and style
so i thought it would suit me better and
it was a wonderful class i was very
happy with it
and then i took a bunch of across the
street classes just for fun
to get a change from the business school
curriculum
so i took some pretty obscure like
spanish and portuguese pastoral
literature
and like medieval retellings of a
particular
myth and it was really just to meet
other stanford people
and get my head out of the business
space and into
something that's already been always
been really fun for me
great and um sebastian you want to talk
about your experiences
outside of the business school yeah sure
so i i
like alana took took several classes
outside of school so i outside of
the business school within stanford that
i i won't elaborate on but i think one
of the big experiences for me
was combining the mba curriculum
and this other degree uh at harvard
uh focused on economics etc and so i
think that
that was challenging for sure because
you're you know moving across
uh the country three times uh you
you need to um miss
out on certain things because there's a
quarter when you need to be at the
at the kennedy school and vice versa but
beyond those kind of logistical issues i
think it really enhanced
uh the academic experience i had i was
able to take a lot of insights and
things that i was maybe thinking from
a public policy perspective at the
kennedy school and then bring them back
and think about them more from a
business school perspective
i had professors who knew each other at
both schools and that really created
kind of a unique way to interact with
with each of them and
and actually jointly on a few things so
i i think that
for me that just really enhanced the
experience
and in addition it was just incredible
to see the support that you get
from the gsb to be able to do those kind
of things and i think evidence of that
is that now
uh one in five i think is what lisa said
of students
do some sort of dual degree or or uh
joint degree
um and so it's become kind of a part of
the community that is
is is very normal very supportive and
that and for me
personally very enhancing to to my
education so i i'm really grateful i did
it
building on that i think one of the
things that i like the most about the
gsb experience is both
the flexibility of the academic
experience
to tailor it to exactly what you need
and want out of your experience
as well as the close integration between
the gsb and these other schools with
regards to the flexibility
one of the cool things is that basically
after your first quarter you
always have some room in your schedule
to be able to fit in
any classes you want from any other part
of stanford
and the nice thing about it is that
you're not restricted by like you can
only take a certain number of classes
you can basically fit in as many across
the street classes
as you can fit within like your maximum
units that you're allotted for stanford
so you can essentially take as many
classes as you want as long as you're
meeting all of your
gsb requirements and as long as you're
within the maximum unit allotment and i
definitely took advantage of that
i took classes even more classes in the
computer science department because
there's just so many cool classes
related to engineering
and i took classes in the law school
which was really cool because i had
never done anything related to law
before
and that gave me a strong background for
the work i was doing advising the fda
and then also i got to explore some new
interests i took
a sailing class there's a lake um
there's like a bay
area near stanford um in redwood city
and
they have a sailing club there so i got
to go there a couple of times each week
to go and learn how to sail which is
really cool and then i also took an
electronic music production class
which was a really cool way to connect
my interest in the arts
with my experience in technology and
that was through
karma which is the stanford center for
music
and uh other arts great
i see i'll go ahead alana just wanted to
say one quick thing which is that i know
this is an academic
panel but it's not just classes one of
the things that was really fun
and i think is underutilized by gsp
students is the ability to get involved
with student organizations
that are stanford wide absolutely
i think um that is had a chance to join
us would you like to briefly introduce
yourself
welcome yeah hi everyone apologies for
joining tremendously late
coming from something else um uh class
of 16
i came to gsb having worked for six
years in corporate finance
and then after gsb uh spent four years
in consulting and now i'm
in the venture world uh in a hybrid
role but mostly a platform role so
working with our lps
and our portfolio companies within the
fintech and banking space
to connect and yeah just
really love stanford and
opened a lot of doors for me and i was
excited to join
today so i'm really sad i missed the
first portion but
happy it's great we'll catch you up
maybe you could share with us one of
your favorite classes or academic
experiences during your time at stanford
yeah um i'll share my favorite gsb class
and then my favorite
stanford class so my favorite gsb class
was
um high performance leadership i
think it's what it's called um i like to
describe it as like
touchy-feely too or applied touchy-feely
um i really took a lot from that class
that
when i was managing people
um as a consultant like came to play
both with our clients and like coaching
them but also my own
team and then outside the gsb i
took um i forgot the exact name of it
but it was an
economics theory class and
it was i didn't intend to sign up for a
phd class but i'm
really glad i did because we just talked
about things that were
so out of the norm of what i would have
otherwise had exposure to
that i think opened the door for me to
understand
certain things in business differently
and i think it was like
economic theory of institutions or
something like that
um it's great great class so
uh echo the take classes outside your
comfort zone
across the street yeah that actually
reminds me of this other class i took
i took a quantum computing class without
any background in quantum compute or
quantum mechanics or physics or anything
and i definitely didn't expect it to
be what was essentially like my favorite
class ever
but just the way that the class was
integrated with technology
physics math and even philosophy like
learning about
quantum computing helped me think about
the world and how
people are connected and all of the
possibilities that could exist with
different universes and everything it
was a very
deep experience way beyond anything that
i had expected
before i decided to take it great
well i want to build off one of the
classes i just heard mentioned
a minute ago we affectionately referred
to it as touchy-feely but its real name
is interpersonal dynamics
and i noticed in the q a section folks
were asking about
classes like interpersonal dynamics or
other great
soft skills courses so does anyone want
to quickly describe what
interpersonal dynamics is and then also
maybe mention some of your other
favorite soft skills courses like high
performance leadership which we heard as
well
i can i can take that since i brought it
up um i presume it's still the same
since a few years ago but essentially
um i would say there's really two
overarching things you get out of the
class with a lot
of nuance sub points you can get out of
it so the face
first major thing is how do people
experience you like how do you show up
to people
and then the second is like what
assumptions
do you make about people as you're
interacting with them that
may influence your behavior for
good bad and different um
and the way the class is structured is
you're in a group of
about 12 and there's a plenary
component each week and then you spend
four or five hours in a room
with your 12 people with a very loose
agenda
and it's awkward and then stuff happens
and then
you all learn and to be really honest
with each other
and there's two facilitators and so
um for someone who's hyper structured
you're just like you want me to do what
um and then eventually you kind of just
see that the group
naturally starts to create learning for
each other
um and then at the end of the class
there's a
weekend or a couple days where you do
really just
that but like for eight or 12 hours at a
time
and then you do a lot of reflection and
a lot of writing and
i think it's a really great course um
if that's a focus of yours um and then
one other class that i would add in the
soft skills
area is um it was a communications class
i don't remember the name of it but
really you're just learning how to
communicate and you have to do
a lot of presentation a lot of different
exercises and i think it sounds like it
should be straightforward
but it you actually take a lot out of it
if communication is something you want
to work on
and i believe the instructor i can't
remember her name but
is someone who's very well known and
the communication coaching world has
been working with stanford students
for a long long time and i just found
her
what she'd pick up about the nuances of
your
not just your verbal uh your oral
communication but your
non-verbal communication to be really
helpful
so we have a great question from an
audience member here
of how would you describe the learning
culture and environment at the gsb
what's to describe the learning culture
and environment
i can go i think one of the things that
really appeals to me about the gsb
is just the collaborative culture i
think like it's not
cutthroat at all it's not like me
against you
like buying for like professors time or
for resources
it's like me and you working together to
uplift
both of us like uplift everyone like
what can i do to help you
to like improve your experience i think
it's all about uh
like growing and learning together as an
entire class as a and as an entire gsb
community and that's one of the things
that i love the most like i've always
felt really supported
um in terms of like emotional support
community support it just feels like a
family in a lot of ways
yeah i i would i would just add to that
when that jorge made
and people who have graduated more
recently let me know if this has changed
but
that there's a great non-disclosure
policy
which which invites what jorge said in a
very
obvious way right no one is kind of
competing when going to a
potential employer or whatever to say oh
i got this great or that great and so
that creates
a a very kind of collaborative culture
as what was saying
the only other thing i would say about i
think a culture that i as i reflect on
both my my experiences uh both at
harvard and stanford
i think the the goal that stanford has
of having all these kind of soft skill
classes
like interpersonal dynamics that nadu
was describing create a dynamic where
people are
constantly asking each other for
feedback
constantly role-playing things uh and
really trying to just
improve themselves as human beings that
i've never seen in another environment
so that that actually becomes a really
cool
uh culture where where it's
encouraged to to to reflect to give each
other feedback to be honest with each
other
um that i think was really unique at
least uh and what i've seen
so uh i really enjoy that as well
we have another question here of could
you elaborate on the extent
of teamwork and leadership opportunities
within the classes you took
i can uh go for that so there's actually
so many classes as people have already
mentioned like startup garage
there's also across the street classes
that bring in students from
all the different stanford schools to
work together so you could work
hands-on on various different projects
like i took an entrepreneurship class in
which we were
designing a business and i was working
with people across
gsb law school engineering school and
we essentially like came up with a
business plan came up with the
financial statements created a
presentation for
a pitch that we did to actual venture
capitalists from
sand hill road who gave us feedback on
our pitch
and in each of these experiences the
cool thing is that there's many
opportunities for you to take the lead
and figure out the dynamic with the team
that you're working on
so maybe in some cases you'll actually
want to be the one that takes the lead
on something
and you'll gain like leading
experience there but also in some cases
actually what's better for the team as a
whole
is for you to take a step back and to be
a follower or to be a supporting team
member rather than the leader in that
particular instance so i think that's
one of the
really cool learning experiences is that
you learn that leadership
doesn't just mean being the one at the
top who is managing
everything and telling people what to do
leadership means doing whatever is
necessary to make sure that your team is
successful
and that can mean working in a large
variety of roles which sometimes aren't
the one
that's out in the front having that very
visible role and it can mean being
a supporter or someone who is providing
a foundation
for the other team members to do their
best work
and you're able to learn about those
dynamics and see how you can fit in
most effectively in different situations
through the project-based classes
here's a question that was directed
towards sebastian but i think
anyone is also welcome to chime in here
which classes and or experiential
learning
experiences were the most useful for you
to really become a leader in your career
um i i think
a couple come to mind one is uh touchy
feely or
sorry interpersonal dynamics uh because
i think that gives you
a lot of feedback as new is saying on
how you come across
and what is the impact that certain
things that you hadn't even thought of
are having on others and so it's a very
unique setting in that front and that's
helped me
at least measure uh more carefully how i
have certain interactions from a
professional standpoint the other one is
the one i alluded to earlier the
managing difficult conversations
um which was one where you're basically
role-playing difficult conversations
firing someone having a big discussion
with a partner
about how you should split um
[Music]
equity uh those kind of things that you
know
are at a theoretical level very easy to
do but once you're actually
doing a role-playing exercise it at
least gives you one rep
uh to have done that before you're
actually doing it live and so i think
those two
for me at these were have been very
valuable in my career
um something i i'd add
uh that struck me from my time at the
gsb is that
i mean sometimes you hear this idea of
like ah did you really have to go to gsp
to learn about marketing
could you have bought that book same for
financing for accounting same for a lot
of things
um one thing that i really valued was
that you have
this combination of industry leaders
and uh world-class
researchers who have curated
all of these resources and what i found
very
impactful was how consistent
the the narrative the values the
worldviews the mindsets were
and lisa i don't know if this is
intentional or no
but uh pretty much everywhere the gsb
i heard this idea of like hey you know
to be a better leader you should listen
to be a better leader you should really
care for the other person
you should be kind you should live by
your values you should do this you
should that
i'm sorry um i think there's only one
class that offers
kind of like the dark side narrative
which is pass to power
i i didn't take it um but i my
understanding is that this professor's
narrative is
yeah all of that is beautiful
but you should not ignore how power
works in the world so this class
is focused on power but everything else
was this very consistent story like even
like how to fire people negotiations and
so on
everything was very consistent around
like hey just be a good person just just
bring your best and actually there's
hard evidence that supports that
this will help you be a better leader
better negotiator better sales person
better boss and so on
and that helped me just cut through all
the noise of so
many gurus and books out in the world
and i was like
okay amazing i can be myself i can be
trying to be a good person
and i can also be a better leader better
entrepreneur in doing so
and have a consistent theoretical base
and evidence-based behind
this uh and i found that super helpful
there's a lot on empathetic leadership
for sure that i that i've heard yeah
here's another um question from the
audience of how did you balance your
academic schedule with
all the other opportunities available at
the gsb and what is the typical
week in the life of a student look like
i see alana smiling do you want to take
that one
i'm laughing because you know i went
into consulting which is
famously a long hours profession but i
definitely have more free time now than
i did at the gsb
just because i scheduled everything so
tightly at the gsb right it wasn't that
i was doing
academics for 60 hours a week but i was
doing
something from 8 am to midnight every
day
and it's just a calendar management game
you quickly decide how much effort you
want to put into academics and people
vary a ton
on that right you want to put in
absolutely enough to get value
out of your classes but you can push
very far past that or you can do the
bare minimum to be learning something
and so that determines how many hours
you need to devote to academics
and the rest of it will fill up with
everything from coffee chats with people
to club events to
foam which is our tuesday night parties
and as long as you keep a good calendar
it's incredible how much you can fit
into a week
yeah i think to add on to that
um the framework that i often give
people is
first start with like what are you doing
all of this for
like if you have to pick three to five
priorities that you're going to use for
as a decision rubric for how you spend
your time
what are you doing all of this for and
having clarity on that i think
makes everything else much easier
because then you can say
okay this quarter this month this week
this day
i have 20 options which of those serve
that purpose
and then how am i going to mix them
together to
make this all work and the reality is
like
if you don't use calendars you're gonna
have a rough
two years um and i think
that you know you have to decide like
where do you need to double down and
spend time i took classes where i
learned a lot
but i didn't necessarily spend a lot of
hours
either because of my background or
because the content was structured such
that
i didn't have to do a lot of stuff
outside class
based on the course itself um
and so you can kind of mix and match
those right like it may not be a good
idea
in the quarter that you're trying to
plan a conference
and also recruit to take a bunch of
classes that require you to do
you know four hours of case reading and
writing
before each class so you kind of just
figure that out for yourself
um and the last thing i would say is um
think about kind of how things build on
each other
as you're determining your courses and
other experiences
so for example i wanted to take certain
classes before i went and did my
internship abroad
because i wanted to take some of those
perspectives
and go see what it looked like when i
was like
on the ground and so those are some
subtle things i would also just add to
think about
i see a question here um touching again
upon grade non-disclosure which was
brought up briefly beforehand and how it
aids to that collaborative
culture and learning environment at
stanford but this question is also a
really good one in that it talks about
how does that actually push you to take
some academic risks and to try some
classes that might be really hard and
outside of your comfort zone
can any of you share an example where
maybe you took a class that was
a little bit scary or intimidating or
outside your comfort zone
i was really scared to take financial
trading strategies which ended up being
one of my favorite classes
because it's a class where you spend a
bunch of your time in class
and a large portion of your grade is
determined by
how you do in these market simulations
where you are trading stocks or options
or whatever the topic of that class
period
is in real time in a sort of compressed
simulation of the market
and i came to the gsb from
zero finance background i had really
only taken my required
first year of gsb finance courses before
this
um so it was kind of a leap of faith to
take that class but it ended up being
one of the coolest classes i took
because it really taught me how the
market actually
works and what options
really are and what they need and how
people trade them beyond the
academic side of it that i had learned
in my foundation
finance class i think i have a similar
story to alana where
i also have no finance background coming
into the gsp
in fact at one of these advent
receptions i met a fellow classmate
who told me they were in pe and i asked
her if she was in physical education
because i had no idea that private
equity was a job
and i ended up taking like over seven
different finance classes at the gsb
most of them i took pass fail in the end
so corporate financial modeling
um the financial restructuring debt
class
these are all things i had absolutely
zero background in and
i think because of rate on disclosure
and generous pass fail policies at
the gsb i was able to take these classes
that i was interested in
knowing that i had no background in them
but wanted to learn more about it
and was able to i think now having
graduated have a decent amount of
finance knowledge relative to before
so great
this next question baby diego i'll have
you kick us off here um but what advice
would you have for um incoming mba
students who are really trying to
maximize
their academic experience and their
their classroom experience at the gsb
what advice would you give people
uh i i'll take the the
focus advice if someone else has the go
explore advice
go for it but i came in laser focus
right like my essay
was about lala it it talked about like
by name this is the thing i want to
build
so that helped me cut through a lot of
that noise of just
there's so many opportunities that you
could take
[Music]
it helped me say no to a lot of things
uh
really focus on uh like what classes to
take
every single project in every single
class somehow was
uh geared towards uh
this organization uh a lot of classmates
used me and lala to dip their toes
into social entrepreneurship into cyber
garage and so on so
that was beautiful and many of the
relationships that i ended up building
with professors with staff from the
center for social innovation
with classmates have all been hugely
valuable
yeah the others want to share advice on
how to maximize your academic experience
i think you should um i
i came in with not one thing but like
three things that i was really gearing
my
academics around one was developing
economies the other was interpersonal
development slash leadership
and then the third one was uh like
strategy and so i think for me
as i talk as i thought about what
classes to take they had to revolve
around that and you'll notice i didn't
say entrepreneurship
anywhere in there um which confuses
people because i managed to
get out of the gsb taking only one
entrepreneurship class
managing growing enterprises and
um i think that like a healthy amount of
uh curiosity is important but that looks
different for everyone and
my biggest piece of advice is like don't
try to replicate what alums did and
don't try to replicate what your
classmates are doing
because even if you do exactly what they
did you'll come out with a completely
different experience
anyway so you might as well live your
own experience and
i think that just takes some courage to
be like you know this is what i think i
want to do and whatever that looks like
just go with
it and the luxury is like every quarter
you can kind of change your mind um
but you only get six of them so
you know make use of them um and so
that's how i would think about it
great advice well i want to be cognizant
of our time so i want to thank
all of our panelists today for sharing
your perspectives
i also hope that this is just the start
of our attendees
mba journey and one way to continue that
is through
mystanford.mba if you haven't already
been to this site
definitely check it out you can create
your own personalized dashboard
that'll tee up classes or clubs that
might be of interest to you
student or alumni profiles that you
might relate to
if you start an application you can also
track your progress through that and
learn about other great events like
today so again thank you so much for
joining us
we really appreciate it and best of luck
on your mba journey
thank you
[Music]